welcome to philanthropy in action
together we engage amazing people who
have given their time talent and
treasure to change the world I am Maxum
thorne and I teach philanthropy in
action at Yale University few
individuals have affected our world more
positively than Civil Rights icon Julian
Bond as a young college student Julian
helped found the Student Nonviolent
Coordinating Committee he was a student
of dr. Martin Luther King jr. and he
grew up to become chairman of the
n-double-a-cp he is a distinguished
professor at the University of Virginia
and American University Julian thank you
for joining us today are your own and
thank you to our students from Yale
University who are joining our
conversation to discuss how Mr Bond
became an activist and how he's become
an iconic figure in using your time
talent and treasure to do so much good
for the world Julian how did you become
an activist and do you consider yourself
to be an activist today I became an
activist because someone asked me to
join an activist movement I was asked by
a fellow student in Atlanta at Morehouse
College to join the beginning of
Atlanta's participation in the sit-in
movement and he was so compelling I
couldn't say no to him and so I found
myself caught up in it and I've been
caught up with it ever since so yes I do
consider myself an activist today
perhaps a different kind of activism but
it's still activism for the same sorts
of causes although the causes have grown
but yes I am still an activist was that
an easy decision though I mean when you
say someone asked you to join the Sidon
we're talking about a sit-in movement in
Georgia in a period in which that was
not a safe thing to do well I knew the
possibility was that we'd be get
arrested I knew getting arrested was
likely to put a mark on your forehead do
not employ I knew that the possibility
was of some harsh treatment at the hands
of the police or white bystanders but I
also knew that other people like myself
young people young black people and
other college campuses like mine had
done this and they had braved these
possibilities without turning back and I
thought I could do the same
I found something someplace in me that
made me do the same and so even though
there was some hesitation I could
overcome it when you made those choices
knowing who your parents were and you
could tell us who the word I know who
they are how did they deal with the
choices you were making at that time as
a young man my parents were academics my
father was the had been the president of
Lincoln University in Pennsylvania and
almost also been the president of Fort
Valley State College in Georgia and at
the time this occurred he was dean of
the school of education at Atlanta
University my mother had been a
classroom teacher and later become a
librarian librarians are there people
interest in education and so the idea
that I would risk my education by
getting arrested or by dropping out of
college was just awful to them but at
the same time they were very supportive
of the civil rights movement and
encouraged me to get engaged in it and
so torn between these two things and
full of my promise that I would go back
to school someday and finish my degree
which I did do they acquiesced beyond
putting your education at risk though
many people like yourself and other
members of snake or putting their lives
at risk mmm but is there their bodies at
risk weren't they sure sure all of us
were but again you thought the prize is
worth the risk the prize was to
eliminate the segregation system to just
did so much harm to black people in the
southern part of the United States and
would do harm to me was doing harm to me
it's cheap and the worth of my college
degree under the system my education at
Morehouse College wasn't as good as an
education at the University of Georgia
and and so I wanted to do all I could to
eradicate these biases and differences
that press down upon me and other people
like me because they were killing me
they were hurting me they were arming me
and that hurt and harm was greater than
what ever heard or arm might come to me
because I was in this movement and Q
Julian hi I'm Stephen banks you've
spoken about the importance of
protecting those rights guaranteed to us
in virtue of where we are born but what
is the role of philanthropists and
active
us in protecting the rights of those
beyond our borders well I think the role
of any of us philanthropists are not in
protecting rights beyond our borders is
nearly the same of course slanderous are
different they have resources they give
but you and I who may not have these
resources have an equal opportunity to
do what we can if we know that some
people are being mistreated far from our
shores and treated badly and there's
something anything at all that we can do
about it whether it means giving money
to some organization that's helping them
or doing something to take these people
from where they are and give them the
middle asleep safe place I think it's
our obligation to do it so whether it
involves going in our pockets and
pulling out some money and saying here
this will help you out or whether you
and I say let's go there and do
something to help them I think we are
responsibility to do them we ought to do
it if we don't do it we're not worthy of
being the kinds of people we like to
think we are do you think that we're
doing more today than at a previous time
to be responsive to the needs of the of
the many I think we're doing more to be
responsible of the new of the needs of
the many mediums are far away from us
then we were in my time perhaps in some
senses to the detriment of those people
who are right here in our own backyards
for some reason I think Americans have a
fascination with people who are far away
from them greater than the fascination
they ought to have with people who are
right around the corner but having said
that I think there's greater emphasis
now in helping people worldwide then
there was when I was at the edge of
these students and I can't say that's a
bad thing I'm in the previous interview
you were a bit critical about how
heavily the civil rights movement relied
on the leadership of Martin Luther King
I was just wondering what you think
successful leadership is whether it's
supplemental to these movements and how
leaders can contribute their time talent
and treasure to these movements without
being the sole propel our critique of
dr. King and
and remember we love dr. King and we
admired him a great deal we thought he
was bravery personified were somebody
worth following the car critique of him
was that he often without meaning to
said to local people I'm going to take
care of your problems you don't have to
worry about these things I'll do it and
I say this is not something he was said
this was something they imputed to him
and as a consequence felt themselves
less likely or less able to join in
helping themselves so leadership is
always a necessary component of social
change but that leadership doesn't have
to stifle and we believe that dr. King's
persona again not through his own making
but through the eyes of others stifled
their own ability to act as leaders so
with I remember I was in a hotel in
Atlanta once having a meeting with dr.
King and passed by a bunch of maids in
the hallway and one of them said dr.
King just went by I know all our
problems are going to be solved now
apparently they had some dispute with
the hotel what dr. King was not there
for their dispute with the hotel
although i'm sure he sympathized with it
he was there for entirely different
purposes but they had transferred their
responsibility to do something about
their condition to this man who was just
passing by so that's our argument with
him and again it was not a personal
argument with the persona it was the
argument with the people who thought
this of him and imputed to him the
ability to solve their problems do you
think that therefore there's there's a
challenge with with charismatic leaders
surely there is a great challenge again
and typically it's not a challenge that
they have engendered themselves although
sometimes they have but it's it it's a
challenge that others have imputed to
them and once imputed to them becomes
realistic and real and so you think dr.
King is going to do this for you and do
that for you and do this for you and it
lessens your responsibility to do
something for yourself no one becomes
free because somebody else helped them
do it they became free because they act
in their own regard there may have been
other leadership figures noble figures
brave figures who helped along the way
who pushed who pulled who did all the
things we expect of some leadership
figures
it was the individual who said I'm going
to do this those are the people who make
the real change hi my name is Leslie
Bowl thank you so much for being here
thank you my question is our last guest
here Bruce Cohen mentioned when speaking
about LGBTQ rights that the fight is
never over and used the civil rights
movement as an example and I just
curious to hear your thoughts on the
statement that the fight is never over
and what you think then main area in
civil rights we should be fighting for
today is I hope he wasn't saying the
fight will never be over because i
believe the fight one day will be over
the fight for black rights is not over
the fact of LBT rights is not over these
fights are ongoing and while progress
has been made in each of these two
disparate fields of endeavor gains have
been made victories have been won this
is not the same country today for
anybody in either of these groups today
as it was say 20 30 40 years ago so
changes has been made and changes being
made almost daily but today is going to
come I believe that will say wow we've
put all that behind us and we've made so
many victories that there's very little
to worry about now the ongoing battles
in the struck the search for civil
rights I think one thing that we've not
paid them as much attention to as we
ought to and this is just one of many is
the problem of segregated housing if you
look around the United States it's still
a matter of fact despite a recent report
by a right-wing group in New York City
that's racial segregation and housing it
almost disappeared first of all it's not
true secondly it's pervasive and thirdly
it just harms people of color so
dangerously and I'm just amazed that
we've not done more about it if you live
in a segregated system of the city yours
and you're black you're separated from
the best schools the best houses the
best opportunities and the chances of
you achieving those things are
diminished because of where you live so
to the degree that we're able to stop
this physical segregation of people
that's the degree to which they're able
to have access to these opportunities
and their condition improves that's
something we need to work on
so sort of on a related note the
problems have obviously changed and you
mentioned earlier that your activism has
changed I wonder how have those changes
impacted your search for financial or
philanthropic donations either financial
or time treasurer talent how do you go
about persuading people to contribute to
the cause you know one of the great
changes I've been thinking about this
recently because I'm trying to raise
money for something else is that in when
I began this I was asking people for
fifty dollars now I'm asking them for a
million and I'm not saying they answered
more quickly to either one of these they
did but but the the ability of people of
means of great means to give hasn't
improved they've always been there
they've always had the possibility but
now I have access to them in ways I
don't think I had access to them as much
now as I as I did then as much then as I
did do now and so the amounts of money
we're talking about a much greater the
amounts of money required a much greater
because maxim and i walked the streets
of new york city nikon rich people's
doors asking them for help and we're
asking for more money than we would have
been doing had we been doing this 30 or
40 years ago I don't know it's because
we're bolder and more able to ask for
more or because we know the people are
asking have more and are therefore able
to to to give more but there is more
money in the world and the need for
money is as great if not greater than it
was before so I'm not sure how much has
changed except the amounts of money we
can ask for and the amounts of money we
can expect to give on that note there is
a there's an argument that the kind of
capitalism that was created and
developed and evolved in the last say a
hundred years has led to the kind of
extreme wealth or greater wealth now
most more people in the United States
for example or Western Europe it is that
you think that that is part of why we
experience greater freedoms or is there
something else
that interacts with with our system that
allows not only more money to be flowing
than say it was in in the early 1900's
but also allows more rights to be
flowing across just you know discrete
groups I'm not sure if there's a real
connection between the amount of money
available and the liberties one over a
period of time there probably is but I
can't think of it right now I think what
really happened over say the years
between 1900 and today is that the
people who were oppressed black people
working people women people in the gay
and lesbian communities all these
disparate people found their voice and
found the ability to struggle and found
the ability to say I'm not taking this
anymore I'm going to fight as hard as I
can I'm going to join in with others of
a common cause to address these issues
and I'm going to reach out into the
larger community and find people there
who are my potential allies and make
them my allies I'm going to do all these
things and these will change my
condition and eventually will change the
condition of all of us I think that's
really what's happened for say from 1900
until today I don't think the amount of
money available has had that much do
with it although somebody could make the
argument and convince me but I think
it's the ability of the people
themselves to do it not not the money
building on that night so there's more
money involved you know I'm thinking I
remember some years ago I had gone to a
wealthy man to get some money for the
n-double-a-cp who I was chairman of the
board and ask him for a hundred thousand
dollars and he said no that's not enough
I was astounded because i was asking
four hundred thousand dollars this man
gave me 20 million dollars with the
provision i spended between july and
november of two thousand so in these few
months i had to spend all this money and
think of this you have to spend this
money you have to spend in a legal way
you have to spend in an effective way
you have to show some result of it I was
lucky enough to find a remarkable woman
named Heather booth who could spend this
money for me spend it honestly fairly
judiciously spend it in a proper way and
knew how to spend it
new who could help her spend it and she
did it but the thought that I would have
somebody give me twenty thousand twenty
million dollars never crossed my mind
until it came into my lap and I've been
looking for this guy ever since take us
back to your sick days when you said you
knew you risked arrest you knew you risk
not finishing colleges that many other
folks how did people you young people
think about this financially in in Harry
Belafonte is a memoir that was just
published he notes that there were
hundreds and thousands of people and
young people and children that were
arrested in Georgia and in Albany
Georgia for example and you had to post
bond and bail where did they think the
money would come from and oftentimes
there wasn't money and one had to raise
money in the north and elsewhere to get
these folks released from prison how did
you and others put yourself at risk
without the resources of who would pay
your bail well probably foolishly we
didn't know the resources were there
when we risk going to jail I don't think
we thought that far in advance that when
I was arrested in Lanta for the first
time I did not think Joe Blow will pay
my bond I didn't know Joe Blow I didn't
know who might do it in fact I don't
think I ever thought about at all I knew
I wasn't going to spend the rest of my
life in jail and as it turned out I
spent just an afternoon and someone i
did not know stepped up and said I'll
pay not my bail but the bail for all of
us are several some but someone's I
happen to live in Atlanta at the time a
community which had enough people black
people of wealth and not enormous wealth
but just ordinary wealth who could say
well I'll put up this I'll put up that
output of that and we could all get out
it's never a problem when you got into
smaller southern towns it was a big big
problem and you had to reach outside of
your own circumstances to get people to
do that but luckily we could always find
people to do it there's always a scuffle
always a struggle but there was always
somebody who'd do it some somebody's who
would do it because never what one could
one person take care of this but they're
always somebody's who could do it
and it always turned out well well in
the end you know where we were and are
the kind of people who said I don't know
who's going to do it but somebody will I
believe that will happen and we believed
we just had this trust that would happen
and it always did do you have examples
of that today sure today I went to with
you to talk to a wealthy man who I
wanted to give money to the
n-double-a-cp and I can remember that my
wife and Maxim and myself just scratch
eyes before God you say this then no
don't say that say this then I'll say
this then you'll say that and so on
finally we got the guy and I spoke in my
wife spoke and Maxim spoke of the guy
said what do you want and maxim said a
million dollars and he said I can do
that I'm is none of us jumped up and
said woohoo but I think we felt that and
this guy gave us a million dollars and
you know we often wondered what if we
had said what if you had said a hundred
thousand I think we would have gotten
that but it's not as good as a million
so we said a million and he gave a
million and he's a decent kind of person
and I think if asked would do it again
but so you ask and you get not every
time by any means but you do it get it
if you ask for it and you won't get it
if you don't ask for it hi I'm Robert
judge Nicki and my question was based on
your experience working on this with
this and CC and in the civil rights
movement what do you find most effective
in social movements and what qualities
do you think allow them to have the
greatest impact be most effective at
raising money raising money and having
impact in a general sense let me
concentrate on raising money in the
early 1960s you could raise enormous
sums of money through the mail that's
still true today but it's less true that
it was then and to the degree that we
could I can remember spending hours and
hours folding letters stuff in the men
envelopes Carolyn's stamping them one by
one you know we didn't have machines one
by one carrying them to the post office
send them off and then waiting for the
money to come
back in and almost every time the money
did come back in and now we're not
talking about millions here we're
talking about thousands and low
thousands but we've always got enough
money to keep our doors open to keep our
staff paid to take care of whatever
problems we had I say that's less true
now because people are less likely to
give money through the mail there's a
shrinking population of people who'll do
that today and so you've got to raise
money in other ways internet fundraising
has begun to take some of the place of
that if you're able to have a large list
of people you can write to on the
internet and say some crisises but just
look what's in the news lately today the
Susan G Komen gantz Cancer Fund cut off
support to Planned Parenthood because of
pressure from right-wing Republicans and
a hue and cry went up around the United
States Mayor Bloomberg of New York City
paid out of his pocket to make up for
the money they had but individual
Americans just swelled the Treasury of
Planned Parenthood because they were
outraged at this having happened so
sometimes you can turn a tragedy into a
benefit as happened in this case but as
I was driving here to the studio I heard
on the radio that the Susan G Komen
Association has changed his mind popular
pressure was too much they realized
they'd done something stupid and tried
to best to corrected by reversing it so
tactics that worked well in my day work
less well or the tack that work best in
my day works less well here but it still
works and their substitute tactics and
you've got to work on them same is true
with social activism marching protesting
sitting in these are tried-and-true
techniques you can use it if you're for
me or against me either way it works but
they don't work with the same strength
that they did then they work but they
don't work as well as you have to find
other ways to do it the reason to it and
again the internet plays a big role here
you've seen internet petitions signed
this petition stop Joe from doing what
he wants to do or make Joe do what he
wants to do or doesn't want to do and
you may or may not assign them but
they're as as soon as one method seems
to diminish
another one appears and I think quick
people who are quick minded in the
activist community know how to shift
from this to this to this this and take
up some other means and method hi I'm
Joan gasps Claire thank you for coming
and speaking of that exposure and
throughout our time together you've
talked about different aspects of your
leadership both empowering other people
building coalitions and supporting an
emerging youth population and and I was
wondering if you could share with us one
or two decisive moments and leadership
and that you face and what leadership
characteristics you think are most
important from those moments this is a
tough question some years ago when i was
young i was elected to the Georgia
Legislature and just prior to my being
sworn in I endorsed a statement issued
by the Student Nonviolent Coordinating
that was critical of the Vietnam War and
if i told you that statement today you'd
say well that's nothing that's what
people say about the war in iraq or the
war in afghanistan it's not in temperate
it's okay but then it appeared to be
radical and many people are upset by it
and my colleagues to be in the
legislature put threatened to put me out
if I didn't apologize or take this the
statement back well I couldn't apologize
i believe to the saving I couldn't take
it back i thought it was right and
correct so I didn't know what to do and
I you know I worked hard to get elected
I'd kiss babies had shaken hands I'd
done all those things and I wanted to
have this seat I'd one and I was exiting
a restaurant in Atlanta and I ran into
the Reverend having at ralph abernathy
was dr. King's closest associate and I
said dr. haven't I know what I wish can
do he want me to apologize I don't think
I should apologize they want me to take
it back i'm not going to take it back
what can I do he said just do something
you can live with and I thought well
I'll do that and I did somebody live
with I didn't take it back I didn't
apologize I stood up for it and while it
didn't happen right away eventually i
won my seat back in the legislature I
went to the Supreme Court and they ruled
in my favor and ordered the legislature
to put me back in so that's always been
kind of a lifeline to me do something
you can live with I never wouldn't do
something i would be embarrassed by
something that i'd be ashamed of later
although i'm sure i've done some things
I shouldn't have done but I I've just
have like that statement do something
you can live with and you know I've
tried to always do something I can live
with and so far I've been able to do so
Julian one of the things that comes
across in your life in the way in which
you engage with people and with
movements is this abounding positive
energy that and this humorous way about
you and also very complex way because
not only have you been an activist but
you narrated a an oscar-winning
documentary you hosted Saturday Night
Live and you did and you were recently
was in the where I was in the
oscar-winning movie ray what is it about
you that we can learn about how to keep
up that that spirit that enthusiasm when
when there is so much crisis around us I
don't know why I have a good-natured
personality I'm sure it comes to my
family and my mother and my father and
the circumstances in which they raised
me and raised my siblings I can't
attributed anything else but that and
that's the only thing I could say resist
it comes on i dunno i grew up on a
college campus and pennsylvania Lincoln
University in Pennsylvania and one of
the young women who grew up on that
campus with me has written a book about
growing up on this college campus and
remember there are black kids white kids
kids of all kinds growing up children of
faculty members going to school together
intermixing with each other all the time
and in writing this book she has
interviewed most of the people who are
my peers people whom I my age as we were
growing up on this campus and to a man
and a woman they described just awful
times the school bus driver molesting
the chilled the girls other people
treating them badly just terrible things
me I describe just a lovely time
wonderful time nothing bad ever happened
just a great day happy-go-lucky zone and
I don't know no one molested me which is
a horrible thing
you know and I didn't know that this was
going on or I would think I would have
had a different take on it but I don't
know why I look at things through
sunshiny glasses and other people look
at them in other ways so I don't know
i'm not saying i was blind to sexual
abuse because surely had i known about
it i would have been you know horrified
by it but it happened over here and i'm
over here and for some reason or another
it didn't intrude into my world and as a
consequence i attribute my years on this
campus is just wonderful years and
almost to a man a woman each of them has
some horror story to tell not about
sexual abuse but horror story to tell
about their growing up years and it
didn't happen to me well the this
actually is brings us to one of the
tough choices among many tough choices
that our students are facing each each
day as they think of themselves as
activists they're faced with they can
save children they can actually pay for
malaria pills they can donate money or
time to an art museum they can provide
resources to a preschool program they
can buy solar panels for homes but it
requires them to compartmentalize some
of these issues that can be quite
distressing is that a necessary talent
to be able to be effective and and to
live as graciously and as happily as as
you have just described probably so but
it doesn't have to be so for example i
think these young people have three
choices in the world they getting engage
in social justice activity they can
engage in social service activity or
they can do nothing at all those are not
really the only three but these are
three choices they have well I've always
thought if you create a world where
there is social justice they will never
be any
need for social service that the if you
have a community that provides social
justice that require social justice the
need for social service will diminish so
I've chosen to work for social justice
but I think social services wonderful
wonderful pursuit in life and the things
they can do in that regard will benefit
to the the will resound to the benefit
of others and we'll make them feel like
much better people so I wouldn't
encourage them to have to feel they have
to do one or the other in fact I think
you can do both or all but they have the
important thing as they do something
that they do something because doing
nothing really means you've joined the
other side and you don't want to do that
dick Posner wrote an interesting article
on this and but it would be with a
different thrust and he would argue that
when we provide philanthropy especially
in certain countries in which they're
failing democracies particularly when
we're providing food or medicines and
social services we are actually engaging
in a practice that will eventually hurt
those people because we're pacifying a
community that will be will be prevented
from engaging in the kind of reform
movements that would change that society
so he would argue that the more we give
philanthropy the more we give social
services we're actually preventing the
the society from engaging in reform
because they're mollified in some way by
this do you subscribe to that so he's
arguing the charity diminish the
people's desire for improvement yes I
think that's BS I think people who are
hungry people who are need ought to be
helped immediately because the what this
person is really saying is that I'm
going to do nothing and let children die
let people starve to death and hope
they'll get their conditions will become
so extreme that there
rise up and throw their tired away well
of course by the time that happens
they'll all be dead I don't believe in
that oh so in which your final remarks
what do you believe in what what what
are your parting thoughts well I think
all of us has a responsibility to the
people around us in our community the
town we live in the city we live in the
state or country we live in the world in
which we we all have responsibilities to
help other people and we all may do it
in very different ways you may do it by
becoming a doctor you may do it by
becoming a lawyer you may do it by
becoming a social worker and so on and
so on or you may the three of you in the
back do three entirely different things
because there are so many ways you can
do these things but you have a
responsibility to do something and if
you become a doctor doesn't mean you
can't on the side do something else if
you call a lawyer doesn't mean you can't
on the other side do something else you
don't have to be a doctor who helps
people although we hope you will be but
you can be a doctor who helps people and
who also does this or that or the other
thing of the other thing because you
have a responsibility I believe to do
that and I believe if you do it not only
will you have helped other people and
that's a wonderful feeling you'll have
but you'll feel so good about yourself
you'd be so happy that you did these
things well well thank you thank you so
much Julian I do Thank You students it
is so wonderful to be inspired by julian
bond here today Julian I loved what you
said as we closed our program because we
can all do something we can all do
something to make the world a better
place whether we're an artist whether
we're a doctor whether we're a lawyer
whether we're a teacher whether we're a
social worker so the question for you is
what are you going to do to change the
world